lava is pouring from one of Hawaii's
largest volcano is forcing around 1,700
people to evacuate the area the massive
eruption on the Kilauea volcano volcano
started last night aerial video shows
lava exploding from the ground and and
flowing into the streets of Leilani
estates
the volcano is on Hawaii's Big Island it
is one of the most active volcanoes in
the world
vladimir duthiers our streaming network
that cbsn is here tracking the eruption
glad good morning eruption never sounds
good it never does Gail good morning the
Kilauea volcano had been rumbling for
weeks and officials have been warning
residents to prepare for imminent
eruption but once it finally did erupt
people said they almost had no time to
leave o lava ash and smoke burst out of
the ground around 4:30 local time
Thursday breaking the afternoon silence
we could hear the lava exploding right
from the house a witness described the
flowing magma as a curtain of fire
another said the eruption sounded like a
jet engine I smelt it and I ran to the
corner and that's when I ran into a
military officer that told me that it's
smoking and I sure as heck enough take
the turn and one of my favorite streets
at least is on fire the island has been
pummeled with hundreds of small tremors
since last week look how deep it goes
leaving sizable cracks across streets
and in front of homes hours before the
eruption a larger quake struck and
plumes of smoke rose into the air there
are currently five active volcanoes on
the Hawaiian Islands four of those are
on the Big Island
but Kilauea is by far the most active it
has been in a constant state of eruption
since 1983 Leilani estates the site of
the current lava flow sits about 25
miles east time-lapse video taken last
week showed the constant activity of the
lava lake inside Kilauea crater
officials have been worried magma from
the volcano could travel underground
threatening homes miles away I ran and I
grabbed the dogs through them and a
crate put them in the car we moved from
California to get away from forest fires
welcome to paradise
two shelters are open for those who had
to evacuate their homes and Hawaii
governor David E gay has activated the
National Guard Hawaii senator Brian
Schatz also said FEMA is mobilizing
resources for the Big Island officials
say there is no way to predict how long
the eruption will last it's fortunate
that no one thus far has been reported
to have been injured right unbelievable
I mean this is the so primitive it's
just right to the beginning of like the
founding of the earth it really is even
you just see that magma bubbling up to
the surface
beautiful majestic about it though when
you look at it it's just it just shows
you what Mother Nature can do but as you
said me honor the best thing is that
nobody was hurt and that's hard to
believe looking at the so far I got the
resident said welcome to paradise right
right for glad thank you